sap a trop changé juste peinture et
howie le terrain grin studios carole
dominique michel était déjà radio-canada
en 1973 lors de l'ouverture du studio 42
d'immensité de ce studio alors ça ici on
était bien parce que on respirait montre
d'un grand studio puis ça on dirait que
ça nous poussait à être peut-être plus
présent et on travaillait très fort ça
va être ça ça coûte cher le studio a
défini la reine du bye bye à accompagner
les téléspectateurs en direct de ce
studio mexique des fois je pars en
courant comme pour aller me changer je
me changeait pas je courrais derrière
les rideaux du studio et je me changeais
celui ci avait des techniciennes et rien
mon but ils ont vu leurs billets ils
m'ont vu pilage arriver parce qu'on
n'avait pas le temps allez olla gina
passion et un live
c'est le téléthéâtres pape a présenté
aux beaux dimanches en 1973 qu inauguré
le studio capable d'accueillir 600
personnes le 42 à héberger les plus
grandes émissions de variétés
allô boubou
star de ce soir
où la fureur ont fait les beaux jours de
la télévision française au pays un
studio qui a été le témoin de
l'évolution technologique et de la
société au cours des 50 dernières années
on a commencé ici le studio sept îles à
sion et en mon nom c'est l'image était 4
3 c'était uniquement des hommes qui
étaient sur les plateaux à la technique
et puis au scénic aujourd'hui on est au
calme à 30 à 40% de femmes que ce soit
pour tout le monde en parle ou pour les
soirs de gala le studio 42 est resté
jusqu'à la fin au lieu de tournage
d'exception ce soir les enfants de la
télé sera la dernière émission à y être
enregistrés j'étais enfant que je
regarde les émissions ici d'être ici
aujourd'hui pour la dernière émission
enregistrée aux 42 le sentiment qui me
vient c'est privilèges désormais c'est
au studio à de la nouvelle maison de
radio-canada que seront filmés les
grands rendez vous télévisuel on a voulu
bâtir sur ce qu'on avait acquis dans 42
je pense que la sonorité est un élément
extrêmement important mais également
toute la flexibilité qu'on est capable
d'apporter à l'ensemble de nos
productions c'est une page de notre
histoire qui se tourne et c'est à
dominique michel que revient le mot de
la fin ça c'est vrai c'est mon dernier
reportage au studio 40,6 nabi alexandre
chartier adieu canada montréal